my question is pertaining to gender
theory so it seems like it's become very
prevalent in academia and even in
in
conservative circles per se the belief
that gender and sex are dualistically
split and one's identity has nothing to
do with their autonomy i mean they're
they're biology
yeah so i see a lot of conservatives
push back against critical theory being
taught in schools right but where is the
conservative where's the large
conservative pushback against queer and
gender theory since it seems like some
conservatives are fine with saying that
gender is a whole linguistic performance
as butler would say or it's completely a
social construct so this is what i do
talk about this in my last book plug the
authoritarian moment
in this book i talk about the tendency
for conservatives to basically give an
inch and then be surprised when a mile
is taken right conservatives want to be
nice we do we like to humor people we
actually prefer not all of us right some
of us are jerks but but a lot of us like
to you know give people what they want
be nice and interpersonal relationships
and so when someone says i want you to
call me by this thing that is not
actually objectively correct
we'll kind of go alright you know fair
enough whatever like does it just bother
me is it really a big deal and the
answer is yes when you sacrifice truth
on the altar of being kind you have
sacrificed truth on the altar of being
kind and it's difficult to get back
truth once you've killed it and this is
and so i mean i think that any
conservative who pretends that it
doesn't matter for example whether a
biological male is called he or she
i don't know how you can call yourself a
conservative or even really a classical
liberal in that sense i mean the fact is
that there have to be certain objective
truths that are objectively verifiable
in the world and we have to use language
in a way that we commonly understand and
that conveys information otherwise we're
just jabbering at each other like
animals and that's that's not that's not
good now as i've said many times if i'm
in a room with a transgender person
we're having dinner together and this
has happened and the person wants me to
call them by their pronouns in private
i'm happy to call them whatever they
want if they want to call me napoleon
bonaparte i'll do it i don't care it
doesn't matter to me but in a public
setting i'm not going to sacrifice the
validity of truth on the altar of
niceness i'm not going to do it right if
i'm if i'm on stage with a person who is
a transgender person i will say that
they are biologically male if they are
biologically male and i will call them
by pronouns that match their biology
because this is what pronouns are
designed to do they're not meant to
they're not designed in order to
describe your subjective feeling about
yourself which is unverifiable by any
objective metric right otherwise we
cannot have a language we cannot have a
conversation so yeah i'm i object
strenuously to conservatives who who
think that somehow these are side
battles they don't matter when you just
focus on tax cuts like i'm sorry but if
if the distinction between male and
female which is perhaps the most
biologically ingrained distinction
in mammalian biology not just humans
mammals right sexual dichotomy is a
thing in mammals it is end of story it
is the basis for all reproduction
if if you cannot
state that and just state that clearly
then i'm not sure exactly what kind of
civilization you think you're defending